make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again
with another installment in our quest to
rid the world of superheroes and super
villains
by killing each and every one of them
and our focus today is on one of the
x-men's most vicious villains
one of wolverine's most ruthless rivals
the soviet super soldier
known as omega red but if we're going to
be eliminating superheroes and sending
them off to the land of the dead then
what better sponsor to have for this
video
than one that deals with the idea of the
walking dead
so do you have what it takes to lead a
community through the world of the
walking dead can you handle the
never-ending roaming walkers as you
scavenge for supplies through the
southern landscape well if you can
then you're the perfect person to check
out the latest walking dead survivors
mobile game with a storyline that's
based on the comic storyline by robert
kirkman which is probably one of the
best comic book story lines of all time
i love the walking dead series it's
amazing but in the walking dead
survivors
mobile game you can build and fortify
your base but not only can you fortify
your base with buildings you can do it
with other people like your own
army now one thing you do have to watch
out for guys
zombies are not the only threat other
players
are threats as well which makes the game
so fun because now it's an attack on
multiple levels
it's what makes the game so cool so make
sure you guys check out the link down in
the description
and get pre-registered to get yourself a
head start
so having said all that before we figure
out how to
take out omega red let's go over his
origin and powers to see what makes him
so hard to kill so omega red was created
by jim lee and john byrne and first
appeared in x-men number four in 1992
which i have a copy of that comic his
real name is arcadie gragorovich
rosovich and there are
actually a couple different versions of
his origin one is that he was a serial
killer that was apprehended by sean
cassidy
better known as the mutant banshee while
he was working for the international law
enforcement agency interpol
interpol then hands arcadia over to the
kgb who see this as an opportunity to
use him as a test subject to recreate
the super soldier serum that turns steve
rogers into captain america because
that's basically what every evil
organization in comics wants to do
another origin is that arcadie was
actually a soldier in the soviet army
he's still a murderer in this version
but this time he's captured by his
fellow soldiers who decide to execute
him by shooting him in the head to the
astonishment of everybody
arcadis survives the gunshot and it's at
that point that the soviet government
decides that he's a prime candidate for
their version of the super soldier
program since then he's worked with a
variety of criminal organizations and
has been a frequent antagonist of the
x-men
particularly for wolverine who has been
his frequent adversary for reasons that
we'll discuss once we actually get into
our analysis
of how to eliminate him so omega red's
powers come from two sources
his mutant physiology and the
enhancements made by the soviet super
soldier serum his mutant abilities grant
him
superhuman physical attributes including
strength speed stamina and durability
as well as the ability to secrete
pheromones known as death spores now as
their name suggests these spores are
potentially lethal
to those they come into contact with
they would kill a normal person almost
instantly but those with superhuman
abilities may only be harmed the primary
enhancement made to omega red
is part of the super soldier experiment
was the implementation of carbonadium
tentacles into his arms now carbonadium
is a metal engineered by the soviet
government in an attempt to create
adamantium it's basically a poor man's
adamantium the resulting metal was not
as durable as adamantium but was a lot
more flexible so a mega rad can use
these tendrils to either bludgeon people
or he can restrain their movement we can
also use them to channel his mutant
ability to produce pheromones and these
abilities work in tandem to allow omega
red
to drain the life from those individuals
that he's able to ensnare in his coils
now once he does this he can use the
energy he drains from his victims to
augment his own strength he's also an
expert in military strategy and
hand-to-hand combat due to the training
he received as a soviet super soldier
and
operative so with all that in mind how
do we take out omega red well
first we need to address the fact that
he's been killed before
in an altercation with wolverine omega
red was actually killed when wolverine
stabbed him with the muramasa blade now
if you've been
reading x of swords you're probably at
least somewhat familiar with the
miramasa blade but for those of you who
are not because you have not
i'll give you a little background on it
because i'm comics explained
and that's what i do here so muramasa is
generally regarded as the greatest
swordsmith
on earth when logan was living in japan
shortly after the end of world war ii he
accidentally stabbed a villager and was
banned from the town at this time he was
married to a woman named itsu
and when he goes back to his house to
say one final goodbye he finds that
she's actually been killed logan seeks
out muramasa
wanting a weapon that'll allow him to
enact revenge on those responsible for
his wife's death and muramasa promises
to make him a weapon
against which all will fall but in order
to do so he needed to imbue the blade
with logan's blood
and a piece of his soul so definitely
like some sorcery going on here now
forging the blade took
several years and when logan returned to
muramasa to reclaim it muramasa told him
to wield it like an angry god which he
does
notably using it to kill a mega red
among several other victims so we know
that it'll work but what if we don't
have
access to the muramasa blade because
wolverine's off fighting people
and rocco with it i don't know whatever
reason you want to use here fortunately
for us omega red has
another weakness that we can exploit and
this one also involves wolverine
as it turns out the carbonadium implants
are actually slowly killing him and
that's why draining the life from others
is not something omega red just does
because he's a crazy guy
although this is undoubtedly true but he
actually
has to do it in order to stay alive to
remedy this omega red needs a device
called a carbonadium synthesizer which
would negate the metals negative effects
the trouble is
this device was stolen by wolverine and
sabertooth and another mutant named
maverick who were all working for the
canadian special ops organization
team x so omega red frequently tries to
track down wolverine and beat this
information out of him but up to this
point
it really just hasn't worked so in
theory we don't really have to do
anything to kill a mega red we could
just lock him in a cell and let the
carbonation do its work and if we wanted
him to end more rapidly well we could
find some way to increase its toxic
effects
through some form of comic book
technology the problem is though
even when he dies omega red rarely stays
dead and our desire here is to kill him
permanently he was resurrected by
members of a russian cult through dark
magic but he was basically undead at
that point he would periodically rise
from the grave but he was never really
able to stay alive for very long this
was eventually undone
and omega red was restored to life he
eventually makes his way to krakowa the
haven for all mutant kind where he's
agreed to operate as a sleeper agent for
dracula in exchange for a carbonadium
synthesizer so
for our plan of using omega red's
carbonadium implants against him we're
going to have to either steal
or neutralize the synthesizer then we
have the added obstacle of omega red
being on krakoa where mutants are
resurrected
after their deaths however if we're able
to convince the mutants that omega red
was in fact a spy
i doubt they would be too keen to
resurrect him and that's the way that we
do this
either we use the muramasa blade or
failing that we find a way to intensify
the toxic effects of the carbonadium in
his body and then in turn we just keep
the mutant population from resurrecting
him from the dead and then he just stays
dead forever but if you guys have a
better way
let me know in the comments and let me
know what other characters that we
should try to get rid of in this series
because i kind of like the idea of
bringing it back but if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and i
will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you